- [Narrator] Consider the left
and right Riemann sums that
would approximate the area
under y is equal to g of x
between x equals two and x equals eight.
We want to approximate this
light blue area right here.
Are the approximations over
estimations or underestimations?
So, let's just think about each of them.
Let's consider the left
and right Riemann sums.
First the left.
I'm just gonna write left for
short but I'm talking about
the left Riemann sum.
They don't tell us how many
subdivisions to make for
our approximation so
that's up to us to decide.
Let's say we went with three subdivisions.
Let's say we want to make them equal.
They don't have to be,
but let's say we do.
The first one would go from two to four,
the next one would go from four to six,
and the next one would
go from six to eight.
If we do a left Riemann sum,
you use the left side of
each of these subdivisions
in order to find the height.
You evaluate the function at
the left end of each of those
subdivisions for the height of
our approximating rectangles.
We would use g of two to
set the height of our first
approximating rectangle, just like that.
Then we would use g of four
for the next rectangle.
We would be right over there.
Then you would use g of six
to represent the height of
our third and our final
rectangle, right over there.
Now, when it's drawn out like
this, it's pretty clear that
our left Riemann sum is going
to be an overestimation.
Why do we know that?
Because these rectangles, the
area that they're trying to
approximate is contained
in the rectangles.
And these rectangles have
this surplus area so they're
always going to be larger than the areas
that they're trying to approximate.
And in general,
if you have a function that's
decreasing over the interval
that we care about right over here,
strictly decreasing the entire time.
If you use the left edge of
each subdivision to approximate,
you're going to have an overestimate.
Because the left edge,
the value of the function there,
is going to be higher than
the value of the function at
any of the point in the subdivision.
That's why for decreasing function,
the left Riemann sum is going
to be an overestimation.
Now let's think about the
right Riemann sum and you might
already guess that's
going to be the opposite
but let's visualize that.
Let's just go with the
same three subdivisions.
But now let's use the
right side of each of these
subdivisions to define the height.
For this first rectangle the
height is going to be defined
by g of four.
That's right over there.
And then for the second one
it's going to be g of six.
That is right over there.
For the third one it's
going to be g of eight.
Let me shade these in to make
it clear which rectangles
we're talking about.
This would be the right Riemann
sum to approximate the area.
It's very clear here
that this is going to be an underestimate.
Underestimate because we see
in each of these intervals,
the right Riemann sum or the
rectangle that we're using
for the right Riemann sum
is a subset of the area
that its trying to estimate.
We're not able to, it doesn't
capture this extra area
right over there.
And once again,
that is because this is a
strictly decreasing function.
So if you use the right end
point of any one of these or
the right side of any of
these subdivisions in order to
define the height,
that right value of g is going
to be the lowest value of g
in that subdivision so it's
going to be a lower height than
what you could say is even the
average height of the value
of the function over that interval.
So you're going to have an
underestimate in this situation.
Now, if your function
was strictly increasing,
then these two things would be
swapped around and of course,
there are many functions
that are neither strictly
increasing or decreasing
and then it would depend on the function.
Sometimes even,
it would depend on the type
of subdivisions you choose to
decide whether you have an
overestimate or an underestimate.